ننتقل الى ديار بكر التي كانت المشاركه
فيها اقل من باقي المدن نتحدث عن
75.90
فقط وليد العطار بالمقارنه بالباقي المدن
كاليجدار اوغلو حقق فيها
71.61 في المئه كيف تبدو ديار بكر غداه
فوز اردوغان
نعم وسيله من واقع هذه النتائج يتبين لنا
كيف تبدو ديار بكر يعني المصوتون الذين
يعني احتشدوا وراء كمالك في جولتي
الانتخابات الاولى والثانيه
لم يفز لا في الاولى ولا في الثانيه
وبالتالي هم يشعرون باحباط وهجوم سيطره
على مظاهر الحياه منذ اعلان النتائج او
منذ تكشف النتائج رويدا رويدا مساء امس
حتى اليوم اليوم الحياه عاديه انصرف الناس
عن اجواء الانتخابات بالكليه الى حياتهم
الطبيعيه اما
يعني لا توجد مظاهر فرح او بظاهر تفاعل مع
نتائج الانتخابات الا في اضيق نطاق بالامس
كان يعني لم نجد الا فعاليه واحده لانصار
حزب العداله والتنميه الذين فاز الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان هنا في في بلدهم في
مدينتهم او في ولايات في ديار بكر
28% هو حقق 26% في الجوله الاولى يعني من
الصعب ان يقال ان اصوات سنان التي بلغت
واحد وربع في المئه في الجوله الاولى قد
ذهبت اليه بالكامل لاردوغان اقصد نظرا
لانخفاض نسبه التصويت اصلا من اكثر من 81%
في الجوله الاولى الى نحو 76% في هذه
الجوله وبالتالي لا يعتقد ان اصوات سنان
وان كانت مؤثره بشكل كبير هنا في ولايه
ديار بكر بطبع بطبيعه الحال لان ولايه
ديار بكر النفس القومي التركي فيها ليس ذا
تاثير كبير يبقى الاشاره الى شيء ان بطي
صفحه الانتخابات
امام الرئيس اردوغان وهو الذي تحدث امس في
خطاب الشرفه عن يعني اعاده اللوح ما
وتجاوز الخلافات وما الى ذلك هو نفسه قد
تحدث
الجوله الاولى بانه قال سنبني قرن تركيا
بدعم اشقائنا الاكراد هذا الدعم الذي
ينتظره الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
سيقتضي من ادارته بالتاكيد خطوات كثيره
لجاستري هو عديده بين
نظام اردوغان وبين الكثافه التصويتيه
الكرديه التي انصرفت عنه في جولتي
الانتخاب هذا العام وايضا انصرفت عنه بنفس
المقدار في عام 2018 حيث لم يحصل رئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان الا على نسبه مقاربه جدا لما
حصل عليها هذا العام نعم نعم